what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting
to a clip from the fresh and fit podcast
it says if she uses this she's a hundred
percent
cheating on you accept it i'm just
curious
as you know a girl i hear what girls say
behind closed doors
and i know what they like say in public
so
i'm curious to see if i agree with what
he says before i start let me know in
the comments
what is a line that people use
when they are cheating okay
this is a very unpopular opinion but i'm
going to say it anyway i think if you're
in a serious relationship with a girl
she should not have an instagram that's
cheating
in my opinion i think a woman having an
instagram is 100 cheating especially if
she has
scantily clad photos of herself on the
internet and she's not making money off
of it which a lot of women tend to do
yeah instagram just for attention you
know what i'm saying and i think for
women attention is like sex for men
so uh you know women love that attention
from from the opposite gender and
if you've got a serious relationship
with a girl she still has a for sale
sign on her neck i think that's very
disrespectful
but that's just my opinion a lot of
people think that's toxic i know you
don't like disagreeing
what's your disagreement with it i just
think that's
i think it's unnecessary i think it's a
part of yourself
it's like why do you think that my
profile has anything to do with like my
relationship with you
that would be weird to me i just think
you have to have enough like personal
like perseverance
to have that like this is a reflection
of me it doesn't mean that i'm trying to
like look for anything
see you might think okay but what about
if she's
posting you like your relationship
you have to realize that women also like
attention from other
other women and making other women
jealous so just because she has an
instagram
doesn't necessarily mean that she's
cheating on you
i would agree i do think it's
disrespectful if girls are
posting like butt pictures and like very
provocative like sexual pictures but if
she's posting
stuff with like her family and her
friends
i i wouldn't say that's cheating yeah
but people on us i don't think that way
yeah
so for example i mean i understand guys
target you super hard on like all your
social media platforms like i
i see that all the time but it doesn't
mean that you have to give that energy
to people
it doesn't mean you want it it's like i
just think that's weird
so if if a man commits to you and gives
you a relationship
uh you're saying that you would not
delete your instagram if he told you to
delete it
no you wouldn't okay i think that's
weird and i think that's an example of
you didn't really like him that much
then
because if he wasn't respected well if
he's insecure about my
my reflection
online then that's too much for me it's
not being insecure it's more like if i'm
taking care of the bills i'm taking care
of you like here's here's one of my
requests
at least don't put yourself out there to
be like targeted by other guys because i
mean if i'm taking that responsibility
then why would you be concerned if i
if the girl wholeheartedly loves you
like that's not a thing
she wouldn't even consider talking to
anyone you mean like trust
yeah in other words i think the girl
should change her instagram and just
make it clear that she's violated and
just not talk to them
scandalous stuff yeah i mean that's what
i was gonna post my ass if i'm dating
somebody but like yeah you know
i'll just say if if i'm dating you i
won't need at least
i have like access to like see what's
going on because like you want a
password
but do you think it's vice versa because
i'm sure these two guys have girls like
sliding in their dms all the time
so i would i bet that they would not
think it's the same that's the thing too
it's like you shouldn't hide your phone
if you have if you're in a relationship
like you don't have any reason to hide
your phone or anything you know
that's weird yeah i mean the thing is is
that a lot of guys won't
admit this but uh they would not like
their girlfriend to have
pictures of her body all over the
internet on instagram and i get what
you're saying
maybe make it profile and make it make
it private and then have like i guess
more modest pictures that can possibly
be a middle ground but in general
how's the data grow seriously i would
tell her you're not having instagram
especially if she's not making money off
of it
because i understand how the world works
with men and women and for women
for men at sex women want attention and
if she's getting attention like that's
just is disrespectful to the man
because she's keeping her options open
what if she does it uh for like family
reasons
like wanting to post so there's there's
phone numbers whatsapp
you know what i'm saying you don't
you don't need instagram you know i mean
it's just that women they
women dislike giving away their
sexual advantage over men where they can
have options instagram is a great way to
market yourself to a large majority of
men
to keep options open and there's a bunch
of statistics too that statistics
that show that even married women over
50 of married women keep uh
a guy in the background and the husband
even knows about it so
i say this again another unpopular
opinion you have to you have to keep
women you have to protect women from
themselves and the thing is this
women are taught modern day women are
taught to have habits that are not
productive to a good long-term
relationship they have a lot of bad
habits girls nights out
showing their ass on the internet uh not
dressing modestly etc
i'm not saying you can't do this when
you're single but when you're with a guy
you should have that respect where you
know you dress a certain way
you convey yourself a certain way on the
internet uh you don't have scantily clad
pictures
in other words if the car is sold you
shouldn't be wearing a for sale sign on
your neck
you know that's how i look at it i would
say
that's a lot to ask like it depends how
long they've been dating but
if he doesn't have a ring on it like
uh she shouldn't cheat or do anything
like obviously that's
a given but like to ask her
to delete her entire instagram that's
that goes kind of far for me
anyways but i've never been one to like
post my butt or anything on instagram a
guy that has like a set of nuts
should be able to tell his girl that and
here's the thing i'm not saying she has
to do it
but what i am saying is if you want to
relationship with me you're gonna have
to you're gonna have to make that happen
because i can go ahead and replace you
with somebody else it's just that a lot
of guys don't have the balls to
tell a woman that you know because it's
politically incorrect to have boundaries
on women
you know yeah but uh that's just my view
on it uh
oh yeah so yeah go ahead um
so the girls have pretty much already
said everything
in the book but i guess like a big turn
on for me is a guy that
can listen to me and is also very funny
it's like i
i live somebody that has like a good
sense of humor
a dark sense of humor i'm very goofy i'm
very weird so i need somebody that can
be
you know like relatable so somebody that
could yeah somebody that can like
definitely like relate to me and listen
to me
stuff like that that that's a turn on to
me somebody that just listens
um a big turn off i i have to completely
agree with you somebody that's just too
desperate
somebody's just just too desperate that
like once i'm talking i'm being myself
or
we're talking and you just want to get
in my pants or every other
comment is like a sexual comment that's
a really really big turn off
yeah do it fellas yeah do it but do it
smoothly
and that right there is exactly why i
would not want my girl having
stupid pictures of herself on the
internet because i know how men think
like i know how women say like oh well i
love you i'm a relationship with you
we can use the lamborghini example yeah
if i have a lamborghini right and it has
an amazing lock system
alarm you know it you know the security
ring is loud as hell and no one wants to
steal it and i park it in the
why would i park it in the hood with the
doors unlocked that's just stupid
you know what i'm saying and that's
that's how i feel if you're going to
have a woman
advertise yourself on internet go to
clubs whatever she's going to put
herself in situations that are not
conducive
to a successful long-term relationship
so and i get it like a lot of modern-day
women say well
i should be able to do what i want but
uh the problem is this
women want a man to be traditional while
absolving themselves of traditional
responsibilities as a woman
you want me to protect you earn more
than you be confident make money
all these other things but if i say hey
listen you can't put your ass on
internet
you're toxic and insecure and it's like
they pick and choose
what they want to take from
traditionalism that makes uh that you
know puts them in an advantage
but the man's roles are always static
while hers are negotiable and
i would agree with this i genuinely
think it's disrespectful if you're gonna
put your butt
on the internet when you're in a
relationship or super like
scandalous pictures the only
caveat that i would have is you're kind
of
excommunicating her from like you know
because your instagram is nice to see
which like your friends are up to and
what your friends are doing
and even people i knew from like college
or whatever
like you could even have her like
unfollow guys i think that's fine
i tell guys on his podcast like if
you're going to be a traditional man she
needs to be a traditional girl
you know it's [ __ ] that you have to
you know be traditional on your end
and provide and bring home the bacon and
be willing to die for the scrum
protector
when she can't even say no when her
girls ask her to go on a girl's night
out that's our
that's my thing simply put you want a
gentleman you got to be a lady
exactly what it is but there's like
different types of relationships too
like some are traditional there's
couples out there that are not
traditional like true whatsoever
especially
you know and those relationships don't
work yeah what if she is it passion
but that's not true because
um he he's very arrogant for somebody
that's never been married or never
really
been in a long term like marriage and he
also wants to have multiple wives
i've heard him say that so he's very
arrogant
coming from that like background as to
what
would work because it's one thing to
like study this stuff out
and it's another thing to literally
watch it go on
and be in it but what i was gonna say is
that if if his premise is right he says
that like
20 of men are alpha hypothetically 80
or beta hypothetically so if 80
of men are beta
then you're saying 80 of relationships
don't work
he's close 50 but
i don't know just my two cents like
average people have relationships and
like middle income
people have relationships you know how
do i know you're still so young
yeah um i know because well over
50 percent of marriages end in divorce
and 80 of them are initiated by women
yeah i mean we've had a ton of changes
though if you look in the last like 50
years
but think about it jeff bezos's wife
initiated by a girl
he was making a ton of money and she
still initiated it and married a
teacher there was nothing because then
the same
it's because of an affair not because he
was beta so it's like how are you
how do we compare this well it's it's
easy
as as divorce rates have gone up women
have become more empowered
right so is that the only thing though i
think there's so many other factors
the main factor is that women are
initiating the divorce so what does that
tell you
i don't think in every case they are 80
but he also has to put into account that
instagram gives men
access to women too so i would
that i'd have to look up data so let me
know in the comments i would
guess that infidelity rates have gone up
for men and women
men have always had like an escape no
offense but like men have always had an
escape if they weren't happy in their
marriage but for women this is like the
first time in society that we're
able to do everything that we want to do
and it's not really chastised anymore
you know what i mean i'll say this birth
control um
you know morning after pills it kind of
saved the way for you guys but let's be
real here
if none of those things were on the
table and you're doing what we were
doing you have kids on the web
weblog you like what i'm saying i'm
sorry you'll be doing it
the most so i feel like at some point
you have to say you know what i have my
role to play
and this is what it is yeah and that's
what marriage is i feel like is
compromise
but i don't know every time i think of
this i look at my parents who have been
married for 32 years they were together
when my mom was 22.
she had me when she was 26 no problems
at all and like that never happened so
i don't know i think that men and women
should just have more freedom
this says that it's 70 and not percent
like he says
in general both of them should okay we
got our chat [ __ ] and on twitch asking
are you really happy with your views
yeah for sure
okay why they don't think
you mentioned that you know modern-day
relationships things have changed
my argument is that the changes have
made it worse so
so um since we're since we're in a state
now where marriages
birth rates are at the lowest they've
ever been right so people are not having
children
uh i would agree more women are single
now than ever before and they estimate
over 50
of women will stay single in 2030. wow
then on top of that
about seven eight out of uh divorces in
in the west
canada united states et cetera are
initiated by women and over 50 percent
of marriages end in divorce so i think
it's it there's a problem here these
modern day relationships clearly don't
work
and i think a lot of it is because the
gender roles have become ambiguous
women have become more masculine men
have become more feminine
and uh it just doesn't work you know
we're trying to put a square peg in a
round hole
and it just doesn't work uh the world
has always existed where
the man is in the leadership position
and the woman is in a submissive
position
and he runs the household he works she
stays at home now does that is that to
say women shouldn't work no i ain't
saying that
but what i am saying is that says gender
roles are ambiguous now and men are no
longer
longer in leadership positions women
find them weak
and they divorce because a lot of guys
are taught to be get with your feelings
get more emotional open up to me all
this other [ __ ] that i tell guys not
not to ever do
because as the man you're the stable
rock in the relationship
she needs to be able to come and cry to
you you don't cry to her you don't tell
your problems you go tell
your male friends your problems because
unfortunately with all due respect
ladies
you guys have no idea how to handle
masculine problems because women live in
a different world than men do
you know you guys have privileges and
accesses that we will never even dream
of getting
you know what i'm saying so you're not
equipped to handle my problems as a man
i go even further that if a man does
tell you his problems and he's in a
relationship with you
the woman's going to lose attraction
because you're supposed to be the leader
you can't be bending and folding and
being a softie so i think
that's why our relationships have lost
and i think you know this modern concept
of men and women is it just doesn't work
um yeah but um and i'll share something
yeah just out to that point as well
so you're saying man i don't disagree
like
it's tough because i really do believe
in choice of the individual
but you have to realize that when people
have more choices they're less satisfied
with their choice
so when you give women the choice to
like go on birth control
and um
work whatever like a lot of times
they're less satisfied with the choice
and a lot of times they don't real
we don't realize the long-term
repercussions
of what some of those choices ensue and
escape right
now and it also like i think has led to
like men being
more afraid of like commitment because
before it was like
people get married like 18 19 20 right
but now
you can go on birth control basically
have a wife like live with someone
for years and have no commitment no rain
and i don't think that's good for women
women have ultimate escapes so many now
you can just hey you know what
i'm not happy in his marriage anymore
i'm out of here i take half his money
so i feel at some point there has to be
like a language okay you know what
yes women do have their rights and they
should have you know uh benefits as well
yeah
but at our detriment i don't think
that's a good idea because now
who wants to be married let's bro here
guys that know the pitfalls of marriage
they don't want to get married
yeah for sure i feel like that's what's
made men
like so unable to get married and so
unwilling to do it because they're like
okay i don't trust women at all
yeah in my comment section of the last
video i asked people
like because most of my subscribers are
men like it's like 91
men which is interesting because i made
this channel for women i swear
um but because of that i asked in the
comments like
do you guys fear commitment for your
marriage and most of them said the same
thing and it went along the lines of
like
i fear being married to the wrong person
and getting divorced
and so that's why it's kind of like it's
like hindered us a lot because now
men are not even willing to do that in
the first place
yes so but that being said is a modern
way helping us
as people or is it hurting us let's be
real here
i feel like it might be hurting us right
now but it's still a path and we're on
that path so in like 20 years i think
that we're going to
find balance i disagree respectfully
let's create a disagreement
guys look at our kids though they're
going to have completely different views
we're like the first people to try this
out for sure so like
for me my parents have been together for
plus yeah talking to mike talking like
30 plus years
and my mom has always told me she's like
regardless of whatever relationship
you're in
whoever you're with there's something
you're gonna have to deal with and
there's something you're gonna have to
not like you know or something you're
gonna have to compromise with
so it's just at the end of the day who
you pick to love and what you pick to
deal with
um in my opinion yeah yeah okay and then
uh
turn offs and turn ons so for me the
biggest turnout would be like brutal
honesty
i like someone that's super honest about
everything
and everything yeah and i think it's
better that way
maybe not emotional wise because i'm
about to say a brutal truth right after
this
even if it hurts i mean i think it's
better than finding out later something
that you didn't want to know and
yeah you could have just known and it
would have it would have been done and
put away
and that's it imagine that men
uh like have sex with other girls and
everything else like that and they have
five accounts or whatever
so i feel like now there's a more access
to different
like right escorts there's off you know
you know there's sugar daddy sites
there's you know a bunch of things
concierge service
you know like what is that i don't want
to know
but everything you know there's so many
different escape routes i don't want to
use that word but
for them like if they if they're not
happy or they're not their needs are not
being met or they feel
a certain way they can go and get that
and it's
i have friends parents too where like
the dad cheated physically
so the mom feels like she like can
emotionally
put away yeah you know for women it's
it's completely different
women don't you know you could go to a i
don't know
to a gay like a guy i don't know like so
that's why women
cheat or that's why women have like uh
like a secret
guy that no one knows now but at the end
of the day i feel like guys have more
like on more like options options
to that world to that world right just
out of curiosity and i want to go around
the table with this because this is
going to be very interesting
what percentage of men do you think are
actually sexually active with women i
know the answer to this
i would say i would say about
60 okay okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
um okay but you say like sexually active
with like once they're in a relationship
while they're singing
like while they're single like sexually
active
guys are out there in the day
marketplace what percentage of them is
actually consistently getting laid
wait okay that changes the entire stat
though
because they're not included including
married or in relationship guys
changes the entire stat oh yeah i agree
with her like 60 70
okay single getting laid i would say
less like 40 percent okay okay you say
you know wait
have we asked this question
i don't know probably like i mean just
right now
i'm probably like fifty percent like 45
okay 50 to 45
okay so like completely single getting
late yeah single
it's hard to get laid these days i mean
yeah men forty seven i'm going to guess
40
okay so another stat that'd be
interesting to know is like what
percentage
of men are in like relationships out of
that stat oh uh
guys yeah yeah i was just about to do it
only about 10 to 20 of men are having
sex
it's even more highlighted in miami yeah
no way yes yeah
so so ladies you gotta understand and
this is why i say all the time
men don't cheat they just have sex when
you guys bang someone else is cheating
for a man to get sexual access to women
is very difficult and a small percentage
of men
actually are out here dating women and
dealing with them romantically
you said in miami it's not like that in
miami it's definitely like that because
in a major city like this
all the girls are gravitating towards
the guys that live on sauron guys that
are in brickell the guys that have money
the guys that
have some kind of clout etc la new york
city
las vegas miami major cities or whatever
it is where they're celebrities athletes
whatever
the women are all fighting to date and
or be associated with the men
when you guys go into a nightclub right
all you guys are pretty attractive
ladies you go into a nightclub where are
all the women concentrated
exactly that is exactly how the real
world real world works as well
the top men have all the women and then
um most of the guys other bottom 80 are
fighting for the bottom 20
of women so and this is why
i think women i women would move a lot
differently if they
understood this dynamic because
most women aren't aware that they're
like that this top
20 or 10 percent of guys literally have
access to everyone
when women say this notion about oh well
it's cheating when you have sex with
other girls or oh guys have options all
the
this other stuff that's that's a fallacy
you guys have all the sexual abundance
men have to earn their sexual abundance
because women only deal with a certain
demographic of man earlier in the top of
the show we asked you guys what do you
guys like in a man
a lot of you guys mention things that
show leadership dominance
uh competence whatever confidence these
are all traits of a man that's been
accomplished and has built himself up to
something
men simply put ladies women are born
with value men must create their value
so this is why a small minority of men
have sex with all the girls
so going to my my point is that if a
woman has sex with a lot of men
with a woman sorry if a man has a lot of
women
he should be able to do so a man should
be able to have sex with as many women
as he can
afford and or has the status to get but
it doesn't work the other way around
you know but you don't understand the
repercussions of that
but a man doing that can
quite literally give women diseases that
they
cannot have kids enough to carry the
rest of their life
and condoms don't always stop them so
that's a very selfish short-term
way of thinking man has sex with more
women it's inevitable that he brings
value to the market
but if a woman has sex with a lot of men
she lowers her value from a marriage
standpoint
so that's the reality that's why i
always laugh when women say this well if
you could bang a lot of girls why can't
i bang a lot of guys and i'm like whoa
whoa whoa like no no hold on it's easy
for you guys to get sex it's very
difficult for men to get sex
you guys open up your phones right now
you're gonna have 99 plus dams from
dudes hitting you up
trying to get laid me and fresh we ain't
going to get a quarter of that yeah
no matter how good looking we are no
matter how much money we have no matter
how much clout we have
yeah i mean i get his point um there's
some things i definitely agree with like
when he was talking about
how modern like women and options
like there's the negative repercussions
of birth control and like women
going to work and all that stuff i'm not
against like people having options
but i do think that sometimes as a
society we don't understand the
repercussions
of actions we make when we're young
so let me know in the comments if you
agree or disagree don't forget to like
comment and subscribe
i'll talk to you guys next time